يتملص والكرملين سندمر
جميع اسلحتكم وعندها سنستمتع
بصراخكم. وفي باخموت معارك
مستعرة ومحاولات للتقدم وخسائر
فادحة. باريس تقف عائقا امام
الدعم الاوروبي لاوكرانيا.
وقديروف يضع مكافأة قدرها عشرة
ملايين روبل انتصارا الشريف.
والحرب السيبرانية بين امريكا
والصين تندلع. وزعيم كوريا
الشمالية يحطم ارقام جينيس ويطلق
اكبر صاروخ في العالم قائلا وان
زدتم زدنا وان اردتم فون المزيد.
قرار عاجل لاردوغان بخصوص الناتو
واثيوبيا ترد على التهديد
المصري. وبعد ان حل الربيع
العربي ها هو الشعب الفرنسي يثور
على ماكون. فهل النهاية والون
ماسك مطالب بدفع الفدية.
الطائرات تصل وروسيا ترد. شاور
بعضهم بعضا اجمعوا امرهم واتخذوا
قرارهم اخيرا. نعم لقد اصدروا
حكمهم على رجل الكرملين الاول.
هنا اعلنت المحكمة الجنائية
الدولية اصدار مذكرة توقيف بحق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
مبررة ذلك لمسؤوليته في حرب
ارتكبت منذ بداية حرب اوكرانيا.
كما تم الحكم بايقاف ماريا
بيلوفا المفوضة الرئاسية لحقوق
الطفل في روسيا. رد موسكو كان
هادئا. مؤكدا بان قرار المحكمة
الدولية لا معنى له بالنسبة
لروسيا. وعلى لسان نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
ميدفيديف الذي قال لا حاجة
لتوضيح مكان هذا الحكم الدولي
مرفقا رمزاوي تواليت باشارة الى
ان هذا القرار مصيره هو الحمام.
ومن الحمام الروسي الى شرارة
الحرب العالمية. حيث اعلنت
بولندا وسلوفاكيا تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات ميج تسعة وعشرين. هناك
اعتبر الكرملين ان قرار بولندا
تزويد كييف بالطائرات هو مثال
على قيام عدد من دول الناتو
بزيادة مشاركتها في الصراع.
واضاف الكريملين انه سيتم تدمير
واي معدات ترسلها وارسو الى
كييف. وان هذه الاسلحة لن تغير
مسار الحرب بل ستتسبب في مشكلات
اضافية لاوكرانيا بحسب المتحدث
الروسي بيسكوف. ليتنصل البيت
الابيض من هذا القرار باعلانه ان
تسليم بولندا طائرات ميدلي
اوكرانيا لا يغير الموقف
الامريكي المعارض لارسال طائرات
مقاتلة الى هذا البلد. فلماذا
تتهرب امريكا من مد اوكرانيا
بالطائرات وتدعو حلفائها هم من
يفعلون ذلك. وبينما تتجنب واشنطن
لايصال المقاتلات لكييف فانها
تشعل الحرب في جهة اخرى. وبعد ان
صرح وزير الدفاع الامريكي داود
اوستن حول زيادة عدد الدول
المستعدة لتزويد كييف بدبابات
النيو بارد خرجت الخالة فرنسا
فرع روسيا المتحدثة ماريا
زاخاروفا قائلة الولايات المتحدة
التفكير في عواقب افعالها
العدوانية المتزايدة المشحونة
بمواجهة عسكرية مباشرة مع روسيا.
وبالعودة الى احد اهم الاسباب
التي قد تقود الى مواجهة مباشرة
بين قطبي العالم روسيا وامريكا.
انها المسيرة الصريعة التي سقطت
في البحر الاسود قال منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجية في البيت
الابيض ان واشنطن ستواصل استخدام
المسيرات في البحر الاسود لضمان
المصالح الامريكية وتمكين
اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن نفسها.
ليأتي الرد من ديميدري ميدفيديف
ان الامريكيين فقدوا عقولهم
تماما. وان الوقوف معهم خطأ رغم
الحاجة للاتصالات العسكرية وفق
تعبيره. فكيف ستنتهي قضية
المسيرة الامريكية هذه? لننتقل
الى ارض المعركة. حيث تستعير
المعارك في باخموت مع محاولات
للتقدم وخسائر للطرفين. حيث اكدت
هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية ان
القوات الروسية تواصل محاولات
التقدم نحو مدينة باخموت رغم
الخسائر التي تتكبدها. واضافت
الهيئة ان القوات الاوكرانية صدت
اكثر من سبعين هجوما على محاور
القتال في الساعات الماضية.
بينما قال رئيس اقليم دنسكا
الموالي لروسيا ان الوضع باخموت
ما زال صعبا وان كييف لا تنوي
سحب قواتها من المدينة. لتتراشق
في الطرف الاخر الاتهامات على
فرنسا. والسبب تعطل خطط
الاوروبيين لتعزيز القذائف
المدفعية لاوكرانيا بقيمة ملياري
يورو. وذلك بوضعها شروطا تضمن ان
تكون شركاتها هي المصنعة لهذه
الصفقة بحسب صحيفة تليجراف
البريطانية. ومن جهتها الامريكية
تبدأ بنقل المعدات الى ساحة
المعركة لتدريب القوات
الاوكرانية بوتيرة سريعة وذلك
بسبب خوف واشنطن من هجوم روسي
شرس باواخر الربيع في اوكرانيا.
ولهذا تضيف صحيفة بوليتكو ان
مئات الدبابات والمدرعات في
طريقها لاوكرانيا. فهل يخفي
الامريكان شيئا? ولم يعلنوه يا
ترى. واذا كانت الولايات المتحدة
تقف مع حليفها الاوكراني فها هو
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ يتجه
الى روسيا الاسبوع القادم في
زيارة تستغرق عدة ايام. ويتوقع
ان يأخذ الجانب الاقتصادي حيزا
كبيرا من هذه الزيارة وفقا
للكرملين. لكن في الحقيقة فالدب
الروسي يتحالف مع التنين الصيني
ضد النفوذ الامريكي. فما الذي
تحمله زيارة شيلي موسكو. وبين
هذا وذاك ظهر الرئيس الشيشاني
قديروف معلنا عن مكافأة قدرها
خمسة ملايين روبل للقضاء على من
سماهم حثالة بين القوات المسلحة
الاوكرانية الذين احرقوا مؤخرا
صفحات المصحف الشريف ووضع ضعف
المبلغ اي عشرة ملايين روبل اذا
تم القبض عليهم احياء. معارك
التكنولوجيا الصينية. الحرب هناك
قد اشتعلت لتتعدد الطرق
والاساليب مواجهات ولكن الخصم
واحد. نعم. انها جمهورية الصين
الشعبية. ليشن الغرب حملة على
التطبيق الصيني الاشهر تيك توك
وبريطانيا ونيوزيلاندا تحظرانه
على الاجهزة الحكومية. وادارة
بايدن تخير مالكي التطبيق. اما
البيع او الحظر. فما هو خيار
كميا اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
الحملة الغربية تتواصل. وهنا
كشفت شركة جوجل الامريكية ان
الصين تطبيق اساليب سيبرانية
جديدة وذكية لاستهداف الشبكات
الامريكية التابعة للقطاع الخاص.
وهذه الاساليب تمثل مستويات
متقدمة من اساليب الاختراق
الالكتروني لم تشهدها الولايات
المتحدة بحسب خبراء شركة جوجل.
انها حرب تكنولوجية شعواء. فلمن
ستكون الغلبة. كيم يحطم الارقام.
ترحيب من العيار الثقيل بالجيران
وحلفائهم. والمجنون يستقبلهم على
طريقته الخاصة. حيث اطلقت كوريا
الشمالية اكبر صواريخها تحذيرا
من تدريبات امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبية. وصاروخ واسونك سبعة
عشر تم اطلاقه لاظهار رد الفعل
الصارم اثناء تدريبات واشنطن
وسيول. وهو اكبر صاروخ باليستي
عابر للقارات في العالم يعمل
بالوقود الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
اشرف على الاطلاق مع ابنته واكد
على اهمية بث الخوف في نفوس
اعدائه بسبب ما وصفه بالعداء
العلني ويقصد بذلك التدريبات.
وها هو الصاروخ يظهر لليابانيين
لكنهم يرونه ككرة نارية تسقط من
السماء. ياتي هذا قبل ساعات من
القمة اليابانية الكورية
الجنوبية حيث اتفقت طوكيو وسيول
على اعادة الدبلوماسية بينهما
وتشكيل جبهة موحدة ضد كوريا
الشمالية. الاحداث والتطورات.
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان انقرة اتخذت قرارا بان
يبدأ البرلمان التركي المصادقة
على انضمام فنلندا لحلف الناتو
بعد استكمالها الشروط اللازمة.
اعلنت الخارجية الاثيوبية رفضها
لبيان وزير الخارجية المصري الذي
هدد بان كل مفتوحة مؤكدة
التزامها بحل تفاوضي. الفوضى
تنتشر في شوارع باريس.
والاحتجاجات تتواصل ضد قرار رفع
سن التقاعد. والرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون يمرر قرار التقاعد رغما
عن المتظاهرين. والنقابات تهدد
بالتصعيد مع ظهور مساع برلمانية
لحجب الثقة عن ماكرون وحكومته.
تصميمات صواريخ سبايس اكس تقع
بيد من القراصنة ليخاطبوا قائلين
انه ان لم يدفع فسيبيعونها في
اقرب مزاد علني. خطوات الغرب
تشتد ضد روسيا وبعد الحكم بالقبض
على بوتين جاء قرار ايصال
الطائرات لاوكرانيا. برأيكم هل
نرى ردا روسيا حاسما